*Background* Waaa~~ 💖💖
WHAT'S UP fellow Memers!
That's right! I'm changing name.
You're not no longer bros .
👏
MEMESTERS everybody.
MEMESTERS.
Meme Family. Meme Army. Meme Special People.
Meme no gender binary group of association.
That appreciate memes.
That's what we are everybody.
Hope you guys can enjoy this new title that I've given you.
Our signature move is going to be the Bro-Fist.
*Laughs*
👏 FIRST 👏 MEME everybody!
Oh my God! It's been so long since I've done this!
I'm like, "How do I fricken do this guys?"
*Laughs*
YOBAMA!
*Vacuum sound*
Yobama has entered the hemisphere...
We knew that once aliens attack,
it would not be pleasant.
But finally, we have evidence.
Yobama exists.
Open your goddamn eyes for once and for all.
We don't know who struck first: Yobama, or them?
*Laughs*
But we know that we are the ones that scorched the sky.
I know what you're thinking, "My God. I'm actually kind of aroused."
Don't look into his eyes for too long.
You could lose your virginity.
YOBAMA.
Just when you thought Obama was gone, YOBAMA enters the battle field.
YOBAMA is your Mama.
*Music*
This is how it all came to be.
Yobama, president.
That's what we thought.
That's what we thought, Yobama was president.
AND THEN... *Cymbals crash* the sky got scorched into Yobama.
Oh God... I'm looking at him.
Oh God, I'm looking at him.
Oh God I can't take my eyes off--guys PLEASE.
YOBAAAMA!!
*Thanos' snap*
*Bass boosted dance music*
How am I jumping if I don't have legs?!
Why is this meme still going if I reviewed it?
👏 👏
This and more, on the next episode of: Meme Review.
*Music*
*Laughs*
So what does Obama and Yoda have in common really, honestly?
If you think about it...
I know it sounds like I'm joking and that this is just a meme.
But think about it, they're both green. They've both been the president. They both take part of the Star Wars franchise.
And they both name contains Obama.
Yoda --> Obama. Do I need to lay out anymore straight up facts and logic for you fellas?
Have you not been studying critical thinking?
*Laughs*
I see how it is.
I bet you're one of those people that believe that Yobama isn't real.
Cringe.
EeeeEeeeEeee-WEE-um-wumb-a-wehhhhhhh
EeeeeeeEEEeeeeeeeEeEeee
WEE-uh wumb-a-weeeehhhh
*INHALES*
A-WIMOWEH, A WIMOWEH, A WIMOWEH
I'm starting to understand the meme that is kind of slightly racist undertones.
PLUS 2 POINTS.
👏 👏
👏 👏 👏
PLUS 2 POOOIIINTS!
That was a joke.
That was a joke everybody.
100% joke.
Joke. It's a joke.
It was a joke. It was a joke.
I don't even think it's racist.
That was a joke.
It's a farce--
Goddammit!
Stop it Vox media!
It was a joke!
Yobama's values... I haven't done a background check.
And just to be clear, his values and ideas does not necessarily align with mine.
I'm just merely reviewing him.
This is just me giving a critical standpoint on this person.
And it's not intended to go any further than that.
So please do not get radicalized by Yobama.
Palpatine: Master Yoda. You survived.
Yobama: I hear, a new apprentice you have, Emperor.
Yobama: Or, should I call you... Darth Sidious?
Man, it's-- *laughs*
There's no info about this meme, like who made this meme?
You know what, I don't want to know.
I don't want to know.
Will Smith: Aw that's hot!
Felix: That is hot.
Will Smith: That's hot.
*Music*
*Bass boosted music*
OHH!!! My God!
Oh my fricken gosh!
*Voice cracking* That's so cool!
Twenty eighteen is just crazy.
We had not just Obunga, but now we have Yobama.
What's next? Bro...bro...brobo?
Boma...brobama?
Oh my God, imagine like, Brobama.
Like a really buff version of Obama.
Like an ultimate bro. Like a really big Chadbama.
Chadbama could be good.
That could be--
What about a whole roster of Obama?
Like a--250 of them. And then you can catch them.
And make all your Obamas fight each other.
That would be pretty cool.
Obamamon.
*Music*
Ok.
So this is how it all went down, huh?
I see.
Here he is.
That's Obama meeting up with--oh!
*Music*
Goddamn, these edits are so good.
Stop using copyrighted music, memesters!
My fellow memester, I cannot benefit revenue out of your work if you put--
I'll just link it anyway.
Cuz it was so great.
*Music*
Oh sh*t. Oh sh*t! I'm sorry, excuse me. Oh shoot!
Yobama is in Smash!
Oh my God, Ugandan Knuckles! Haven't seen him in years!
Honestly, looking back.
In retrospect, it should've been obvious that Obama is Yobama.
The evidence was pretty clear, I mean he basically spelled it out for us.
Oh my God, he's right fricken there!
I mean, how could we have missed that?
He was right there!
Clear mainstream media bias.
That favors Yobama and trying to hide the lies about yo Mama.
I'm gonnna give the Yobama meme a...
*Birds chirping*
*Will Smith's phone dings*
Will Smith: Yahh!
*Laughs*
Guys, I don't know if you knew this, but the YouTube Rewind 2018 was really bad.
I don't know if anyone said this before, but it was not good.
When you browse by hot, now that's hot.
Good meme. Really good meme. At least we can have some good memes out of this.
Now Will Smith, who's a YouTuber, a fellow YouTuber, has become a meme.
What if Will Smith hosts meme review?
Oh wow, things that will never happen.
It was pretty clear that this moment with Will Smith in the YouTube Rewind was going to become a meme just for,
I feel like they even knew themselves, Rewind, that it was going to become a meme.
*a different ad for this game? wow amazeballs*
>sub pewds, unsub t series.
>pew you look like ur gonna cry r u ok
>also do your hair thats ugly
>sub DJ_Wolff lol jk i have bad contentacitoes